This is the Chris Abraham Show.
Hey there, this is Chris Abraham
season five.
Episode 3333 is the magic, #33
is the magic number in the
morning.
This is the Chris Abraham Show
and I am completely lost my wig
because believe it or not, I was
watching Jimmy Dore show.
On YouTube and he had a clip
from Amy Goodman from Democracy
Now who is actually saying for
example the US media is
whitewashing the Neo Nazi
influence in Ukraine which up
till now has been completely
whitewashed and she also.
Shared the fact that the CIA has
undue and out of proportion
influence on the Ukraine
missions and the Ukraine war,
and that rhymes so beautifully
with the exact playbook from
Vietnam and the entire world of
of.
Spooky Mcspook faces who got up
in there and puppeteered the
entire war in Vietnam, Cambodia
and Laos.
Or as the Thai say Lao Lao and I
I am amazed by that because even
Amy Goodman has been warmongery.
Mick Warface and everybody's put
their scruples and their
liberalism and their antiwar and
their hippiness on a hold
because for whatever reason,
everybody's completely frothing
at the mouth.
And absolutely, I mean, the
entire country has roid rage.
About what is happening in
Ukraine.
And you know, I'm the guy who's
always said Ukraine is not the
innocent in this.
America is not the innocent in
this.
Russia is not the monster in
Putin is not the enemy in this
he is the opponent, but he's not
the enemy.
And you can blame a victim.
If your victim has been lying to
you for 30 years, making
promises and slowly fomenting
color revolutions on the
countries around you, slowly
rolling to your front door, and
because of the fomenting of
revolutions and the placement of
puppet democracy governments
slowly over time, when?
All these satellite countries
from the former Soviet Union
were on their knees and
suffering from great levels of
of poverty and hunger.
Thank you Ronald Reagan, that
they were easy to take advantage
of and they did opt in.
But how much duress and how much
CIA influence and how much?
Oligarchic and elite influence,
And how much influence from the
EU and from NATO?
And so when you go ahead and you
say me, I'm not
imperialistically rolling up to
the border with Russia.
And no, no, Russia's bad and
China's bad, even though we
completely have a noose of
bases.
And nukes around Russia's neck.
I mean, the noose has been
tightening around Russia's neck
with American imperialism and
very literally our nukes and
missiles that something was
going to give and we're really,
we all should be extremely
grateful that this is the worst
of it so far.
But yeah, so.
That's my thing.
Looks like it's turned a corner.
It's so great that Tucker
Carlson has taken out every
single opponent to Trump in the
most recent kind of blaze like
Liberty Leadership Conference
by, you know, making every
single, every single
presidential hopeful for the
Republican side.
Make them look like a
completely.
Cold War Russian anti anti
Soviet like War Horse, old old
CCCP Soviet Union War Horse.
They all sound like frickin.
I don't know. 1950s and 60s,
anti communist Russia.
Defiant.
We must.
We must remove the fangs of
Russia because Russia has
actually shown no sign 0 sign of
imperialism the other way,
right?
Zero sign.
The only reason Russia ever went
ahead and you know, invaded, so
to speak, Crimea and now eastern
Ukraine and possibly all of
Ukraine, is because.
Is because let's say you hear
the rattle of a rattler and you
hear the rattle of a rattler and
you're like, we must defang the
rattlesnake, we must defang the
rattlesnake and the rattles
rattling for 30 years.
And it's rattling, it's
rattling, it's rattling.
And then you go to defang the
rattlesnake and you get this
shit bit out of you and you get
injected with rattlesnake venom
and you're like.
What happened?
That rattlesnake?
I'm the victim.
That rattlesnake attacked me.
And actually rattlesnakes are
terrible at being covert.
Rattlesnakes go.
Rattle ride a, ride a, ride a,
ride a, ride a rattle, rattle,
ride a, ride a, ride a, ride a,
ride a Rattle, rattle, rattle
ride a ride a, ride a, ride a,
ride a.
Rattle, which is a signifier
through the way they look and
the fact that they're right in
front of you and the fact that
they're rattling.
And the fact that they have
fangs.
And apparently according to
movies, they hiss.
And then if you get bit by 1:00
because you were stupid enough
to think that you had the
ability to to capture the
rattlesnake and defang it, and
then you get the shit bit out of
you and 300,000 Ukrainians die.
Maybe 600,000 Ukrainians die,
then who's the stupid one?
Is the.
Is the rattlesnake bad, even if
the rattlesnake is giving you
like 30 years of rattling?
Or are you bad for saying
rattlesnake should not exist and
rattlesnakes are a threat to my
shins, and rattlesnakes are by
their very nature rattly snaky
and poisonous.
And rattlesnakes are never to be
just left alone, to be rattly
and snaky and venomy on their
very own so.
It's a turning point.
Like to see Tucker Carlson and
one-on-one day completely
destroy the entire Republican
base by calling them warmongers,
By calling them bullshit
artists, by calling them, what
is it called?
Military, Industrial, military,
industrialists and.
And warmongers and and and
adventurous and and
imperialists.
And also unable to look at their
own.
You know what is it called?
America is not what is the term.
I I wrote an amazing article.
It's my only amazing article.
So I'm not being that arrogant.
But the quote is like America
does not go in search of
monsters to destroy is not our.
Tagline or our motto or anything
to do with America anymore.
America totally goes globally on
missions to destroy monsters.
We are self appointed.
What is it called Saint George.
We're we're we're self appointed
globes, Saint George.
And everything that is not
exactly compliant.
And basically any place that is
not an American colony.
And you can tell, I'm sorry
guys, if you have an American
base in your country, you are
not an independent country.
If you accept money, if you are
in NATO, if you are part of
probably even the United Nations
if you have an American base.
You've got a black site.
If you have anything more than
just an embassy on your if you
have a freaking Air Force Base,
if if literally America can take
off and land in your country
without asking your permission,
then you are in fact an American
colony.
We say it's democracy.
We say that you have severity.
You say that you as a country
have agency, but you want to see
how well that works out for
countries like Poland and
Hungary and Russia and Syria and
Iraq and Afghanistan and Iran
and and I would say Israel and I
would say Saudi, but that's
patently and true.
They have enough leverage and
enough power and enough
influence.
But look how that's worked for
Nicaragua.
Look how that's worked for.
Look how that's worked for
Mexico.
Look how that's certainly works
for Cuba and poor little Haiti,
poor little Haiti.
And at the end of the day, if
you have American servicemen.
Or anybody from the State
Department or Spooky Mcspook
face, or any eyes of the Five
Eyes, you are an American
colony.
And by American colony, based on
what my Starbucks friend says,
you are a colony of the City of
London.
Because According to him,
America is just the big guy.
Behind the little guy who is the
City of London, who in fact
makes all the decisions and
writes all the checks.
So, so you know kind of like a
Mark Harrison Chris Abraham kind
of thing.
Little Mark had all the you
know.
Anyway, here we go.
You want to hear a big truck?
A littler truck.
Those are dump dumpy Mcdumphase
trucks and I'm heading I'm and
screw it.
I'm heading to Idido's now to
get to cafe and Umbote though,
and then I will go to the.
I go to library and work until
wheat or bente Ora.
So I did.
I don't know if you listen to
the latest podcast, but
yesterday or the day yesterday
or the day before I completely
had my entire thermos of black
coffee.
Thank God.
Spill into my super expensive
Coyote Brown Coyote Ugly.
Completely customized by scars.
Super Duper Go Ruck GR126 liter
bag covered in coffee.
So I took it into the bath with
me today after soaking it in
bathwater.
Clean bathwater with Dawn soap
in it.
And then I took a shower with it
and now it's hanging upside down
in the shower.
And when I get home today after
letting it drip out, I will
bring it out into an area place
where it can air out.
And then I decided to celebrate
a new gig with a new client with
lots of hours.
I decided to celebrate by
ordering a 30 pound plate.
From Go Rock for my bag.
So I'm going to upgrade from £20
to £30 which means my daily bag
is going to weigh 24 kilograms,
£53 which is the number that I'm
excited to be at and I feel like
I can do it.
I feel like I can add another
£10 and it'll be okay.
Whereas yesterday I was out and
the guy who runs the.
The fountain at the Kitty park
was there and he rolled up and
he had reggae playing and we
sang along together in Mirth.
Everything's going to be
alright.
Everything's going to be alright
anyway.
Love you guys.
Talk to you soon.
Bye.
Thank you for listening to The
Chris Abraham Show.
Make sure you subscribe so you
don't miss any future episodes.
Until next time.
SMS Khan.